before last year's Russian invasion
Alicia skalska and her husband Roman
used to go for walks in this park beside
the cemetery now she's burying him here
next to so many others because the
cemetery is full
they were married in June just a small
ceremony she says they plan to have a
larger one after the war Roman had
started his own business but after
Russia invaded he became a soldier sent
to the front lines on the other side of
the country before Christmas he was
asked by a local reporter to record a
holiday message
dear ukrainians Happy New Year and merry
Christmas he said we the Armed Forces of
Ukraine will try to give you the best
gift thank you for your support happy
holidays a few weeks later the 26 year
old was killed by a Russian mortar
he was so responsible he loved playing
with his nephews says his mother now
left to bury her son Licia is now a 24
year old Widow
we had so many beautiful memories
together she says
I have lost a lot of friends this year
her husband was one of three soldiers
buried on this day over the past year at
this Garrison Church in Western Ukraine
funerals have become an almost daily
heart-wrenching ritual
the church holds funerals very often the
priest says we are tired from funerals
Global News first visited this church
last March during the early days of
Russia's full-scale invasion
seeing firsthand the intense grief
at funerals for some of the first
soldiers killed
one year later their morning feels more
subdued
people have been crying for a year he
says people are exhausted and yet they
push forward
shuffling past rows of generators that
now power cities like levied the
electricity grid under constant Russian
attack the threat of long-range missile
and drone strikes now routine it's
almost a year of this now how are you
how are you feeling how are people
they're so tired after uh
was an I.T professional before The
Invasion and served with Roman in
Donetsk day by day the war became the
part of your life and unfortunately
unfortunately uh is this like a normal
lifestyle for you and it is disgusting
the cemetery and the church church are
filled with the faces of those lost
along with photos of their children left
behind
but even as the number of dead grows so
too does their resolve
we can't bring Roman back but we can win
she says please say in your report that
we need more help more weapons
people are tired but the main thing they
want is Victory the priest says it's
their life it's their country so they
understand it's not possible to rest at
the moment
to ensure their loved ones did not die
in vain Jeff Semple Global News Live